So this is a really interesting
little story about jealousy, envy,
double standards, probably about sexism as well.
It's really about a lot of different things and
it relates to the soon to be first lady
of the United States. As many of you know,
Joe Biden's wife is Jill Biden. Jill Biden is the
incoming first lady of the United States. Jill
Biden has a doctorate in education and she's often
referred to as Dr. Jill Biden. Now, she doesn't
introduce herself that way. She doesn't say hi.
Oh, Mr. Mr. Eggman in Iowa. Voter. Yes, hi. I'm
Dr. Jill Biden. No, but she's referred to as Dr.
Jill Biden by many. Now, it's true that she's not
a medical doctor. That is not a secret. That is
not you've not uncovered some deception. And the
fact that she is being referred to as Dr. Jill
Biden, partially without being a medical doctor
is triggering trumpet's in absolutely hilarious
fashion. And there are regularly questions about
why is she being called Dr. Jill Biden. And
recently, a guy named Joseph Epstein actually
wrote an op ed in the Washington The Wall Street
Journal. Imagine actually saying, here's something
I want to weigh in on, saying Dr. Jill Biden
sounds fraudulent, really. Only medical doctors
should be calling themselves doctors. Now, the
calling themselves thing is interesting because,
again, other people are referring, you know, the
media might say or please welcome President elect
Joe Biden and Dr. Jill Biden or whatever. She's
not insisting excuse me, that's Dr. Jill Biden to
you. But this is actually a really old trope and
discussion. This is this is not new to Jill Biden.
And the goal of the writer is made even more
clear by his suggestion that instead of doctor,
she'd be called Madam First Lady or Mrs.
Biden or Jill or Kiddo, which, of course,
is increasingly patronizing as you go through the
list of names that Joseph Epstein says should be
applied to Jill Biden. Now, one of the reactions
to this is this is merely sexism, OK? The the
the claim being if Jill Biden were a man, if it
was if it was, you know, Dr. Jeremy Biden, nobody
would be triggered about the use of the term
doctor, even if it was a doctorate of education
rather than a medical doctor. I do believe
there is a degree of that for sure. There's
no doubt that this partially is a story because
it's Jill Biden and not Jeremy Biden or a man.
But there's actually more to this because there
are some who are saying the issue is the term
doctor isn't relevant to the job she will be
doing as first lady. And that's why she shouldn't
be referred to as Dr. Jill Biden. Well, maybe, but
if the issue is the term doctor and its relevance,
why do we constantly refer to Dr. Ben Carson
when we talk about secretary of Housing and
Urban Development? And what I mean by that is Dr.
Ben Carson is a medical doctor, but he's secretary
of HUD, a position for which I mean, first of all,
a position for which he's totally unqualified. But
there's glee over referring to Dr. Ben Carson
because Trump has a doctor working for him.
But being a surgeon is completely irrelevant to
housing policy. So if it's very transparent to say
it's a it's a question of relevance, I would argue
having a first lady with this higher degree of
education is more relevant than a surgeon running
housing policy. That's just me, though. That's if
they want to play the relevance game, which to me
does expose that. At least part of this is, is the
gender aspect. And of course, we also have so
many examples from history of nonmedical doctors.
Dr. Martin Luther King Jr., was that relevant? I
mean, I think so, yeah. It was I don't remember
if it was a doctorate in comparative religion or
theology of some kind. And he was a reverend. So,
yeah, I mean, it certainly sounds relevant and it
was not a medical doctor. And then, you know, to
really play this game. What about Bill Cosby? Bill
Cosby also had a doctorate in education, which he
actually actually received at my alma mater, the
University of Massachusetts, Amherst. And when
some were trying to defend him from the numerous
sexual assault claims, you would constantly hear
Dr. Cosby would never do this. How was a
doctorate in education relevant to sex assault?
So I think you see the point. And for me, it's
less about figuring out is it merely sexism? For
me, it's bigger than that. And this is there's a
paradigm shift coming in the White House in terms
of president and vice president and identity. And
there's a group in this country that hates all of
it. They don't like that the vice president is
a black Asian woman. They don't like that the
second gentleman is going to be a Jewish man. They
don't like that there's a number of Jewish folks
on Biden's cabinet and they don't like that
the first lady has a doctorate and sometimes
is referred to that is referred to in how she
is addressed. And part of this is insecurity
about themselves and education and knowledge.
Imagine feeling so threatened, so insecure
about the first lady having a doctorate that
you go through the trouble of writing an op ed
suggesting she not use it in her name. And that's
really what this is about. Now, let's circle back.
I agree. I will never deny that people who insist
on being called doctor in nonacademic settings is
often a huge sign of pretension, whether you're a
medical doctor or not. I have stories of a guy I
knew with a doctorate in sociology who used
it to sort of try to flexin everything from
restaurant reservations. Yes, it's it's under a
Dr. Caster bomb. Yeah. It's like getting priority
treatment on flights. And don't don't you have
my reservation? I'm Dr. Eggman or whatever.
That's that's pretty cranky. That's not what's
going on here. I've never even heard Joe Biden
correct anyone and say that's Dr. Jill Biden,
please. So this is an absolute and total joke.